[Applauso]
buongiorno tocca a me aprire in questa
giornata
io sono stata presidente dell'ati
dell'associazione per il disegno
industriale e la prossima settimana la
torino ci sarà l'assemblea mondiale e
diventerò assumerò questo nuovo incarico
sono già state lette due anni fa in
corea ma viene ufficializzata entra in
carica
la prossima settimana in italia dopo 60
anni questa associazione che si chiamava
international council of society of
industrial design ha cambiato nome
diventa un world organization e dall 83
non c'era più un congresso in italia e
devo dire torino ha deciso di ospitare
questo evento mondiale durante questa
settimana la città che ospita questo
evento in cui io entrerò in carica avrà
l'onore di avere questo nuovo impegno la
città organizzato un'intera settimana a
60 eventi e 8 talks ufficiali verranno
persone da tutto il mondo io sono
curatore scientifico anche della
settimana quindi immaginate il il lavoro
che si è concluso si è concluso che
inizierà martedì ma che si è concluso
con la presentazione della conferenza
stampa quindi potrei stupirvi con
effetti speciali farvi vedere filmati
farvi vedere tutti i prodotti
straordinari del design italiano che
negli ultimi anni abbiamo selezionato
dalle ferrari alle ducati però forse
sarebbe troppo facile in questo contesto
parlarvi solo del design
invece vorrei parlarvi siccome mi è
stato chiesto di parlare dei motivi che
hanno portato al mio eventuale successo
e poi di innovazione e tradizione
vorrei parlare un po del millesi e di
una storia di un topolino di campagna
come me che parte da bella e diventa
presidente di questa associazione
mondiale perché perché la storia può
essere interessante adesso vi faccio
vedere poche immagini di questa
associazione mondiale che riunisce
quaranta paesi 140 organizzazioni e che
è distribuita nei sei continenti
nell'assemblea che faremo si parlerà non
più di prodotti ma del design impegnato
per ottenere gli obiettivi questi
diciassette gauche delle nazioni unite
che sono obiettivi di tutti cioè il
design che si impegna come
l'architettura come tutti ormai nel
costruire un mondo migliore
world design capital world design impact
price world design
sono tutte attività che vengono svolte
nel mondo e che appunto fino a ieri
promuovevano il disegno industriale e da
ora in avanti promuovono il progetto di
un mondo migliore quindi anche
all'interno dell'associazione c'è un
gran dibattito e un grande cambiamento
naturalmente io sono da un lato è citata
dall'altro spaventata nell'intraprendere
questo nuovo percorso però vado avanti
senza le immagini però sono biellese
sono nata bl mio padre di valle mosso
mio padre mi ha sempre detto su 100
persone che vogliono arrivare solo un
arriva e poi naturalmente lo faceva per
proteggere il mio e poi un'altra frase
che mi rimetterò ripeteva sempre era si
è sempre fatto così perché bisogna
cambiare
invece io fin da piccola volevo essere
quell 1 fra le cento persone che voleva
arrivare
e fin da piccola volevo sempre pensare
le cose in modo diverso mi sdraiavo sul
divano con la testa all'ingiù immaginavo
di camminare sulla stanza al contrario
trovando non so il lampadario che
spuntava dal soffitto quindi c'è sempre
stata la voglia di vedere
le cose reali sotto un altro punto di
vista questo forse fa parte della
creatività però per affermare questa mia
personalità ho dovuto lottare parecchio
perché i biellesi come mio padre sono
con i piedi per terra
tutto ciò che ha a che vedere con la
bellezza sono delle storie no per cui
dovevo vincere naturalmente mio padre
era molto più forte di me quindi dovevo
vincere questa resistenza per affermare
mie idee ma non ero sicura delle mie il
mio nonno invece diciamo sotto sotto
finanziava la mia crescita mi comprava i
libri mi ha comprato di nascosto una
macchina con cui andavo a milano
all'insaputa di mio padre a studiare
quindi diciamo che avevo un aiuto e
invece mia madre poi mi ha sempre
permesso di fare tutto ciò che volevo
però ogni scarrafone è bello a mamma sua
e quindi diciamo che questo non fa testo
quindi ho dovuto vincere in queste
resistenze e poi ve la faccio breve sono
stata al primo presidente dell'ordine
degli architetti per due mandati sono
stato presidente della delegazione della
di a torino sono diventata presidente in
accenderà le da sottovento presidente
nazionale internazionali adesso hanno
scoperto che c'è vita su marte quindi
sono preoccupata perchè poi mi verrà al
tarlo di fare il presidente
intergalattico però michelangelo
pistoletto che parlerà dopo è già andato
nello spazio quindi un biellese che ci
rappresenti se c'è posso stare più
tranquilli per cui lo diciamo perché
tutta questa voglia di presidenza
sicuramente c'è dell'ambizione
sicuramente c'è la voglia di arrivare ma
anche la voglia di poter partecipare con
uno status sociale al cambiamento del
mondo cioè come architetto e come design
penso che al di là del lavoro
professionale ci sia un impegno nei
confronti della collettività
tu fai il tuo lavoro ma parallelamente
devi anche attraverso otto lavora per un
impegno nel modificare il mondo in modo
migliore e il design mi ha dato la
possibilità di sperimentare questo
percorso nel 2008 punto c'è stato il
compasso d'oro a torino per la prima
volta quei milanesi che si uniscono il
quanto e poi c'è stato il compasso d'oro
a roma
ecco potrei farvi vedere questo
l'orologio che al polso la lawrence dopo
anni anni ha vinto il compasso d'oro
macchine barche persone eventi mostre in
italia nel mondo e attualmente nelle
giurie
il mio compito era non tanto selezionare
i prodotti ma selezionare le persone che
selezionavano l'innovazione e mentre in
passato il design
cercava di raggiungere un'armonia tra la
forma e la funzione cosa che oggi si dà
per scontata
quello che si seleziona sempre più e
l'innovazione che c'è in un prodotto può
essere una piccola parte di innovazione
una grande parte e oggi il design si sta
ampliando sempre di più a tutto il
processo cioè l'innovazione viene messa
nell'intero processo e viene
scandagliata esaminata fatta emergere
anche tra coloro che producono dei
semilavorati o coloro che non
raggiungono le luci della ribalta perché
non hanno un prodotto finito e invece
soprattutto in italia lì c'è tantissima
innovazione quindi si tratta di andarla
a scovare valorizzarla e questa
selezione compasso d'oro è uno degli
strumenti per andare a selezionare tutto
questo
il designer inoltre oggi è una
umanizzazione di tecnologie
cosa significa che questo dualismo tra
il mondo scientifico e il mondo
umanistico
secondo me cambierà
non ci sarà più il designer una persona
che per la sua cultura la sua
preparazione deve non è un artista deve
creare dei prodotti che siano vendibili
che piacciano le persone che conoscendo
giusto prezzo quindi è una persona molto
curiosa immersa dentro la realtà che
però deve arrivare a usare la propria
creatività per creare dei prodotti che
siano reali e concreti e quindi deve
fare uno sforzo di comprendere il mondo
che ti circonda e oggi noi siamo
all'interno di una nuova rivoluzione c'è
stata la rivoluzione industriale e noi
ora siamo nella rivoluzione digitale
come all'inizio della rivoluzione
industriale
le persone erano terrorizzate da questa
nuova tecnologia che poi ho portato alla
democratizzazione dei prodotti la
possibilità per tutti di avere tante
cose belle
oggi allo stesso tempo c'è la paura di
questa tecnologia digitale perché
anche i progetti di design prodotti si
fanno sempre più materiali ma il
pericolo è che anche le decisioni nel
prossimo futuro vengano prese dalle
macchine quindi per esempio in questi
giorni a torino faremo un incontro che
si intitolerà design e democrazia
proprio per andare a esplorare tutti
quei punti dubbi e per aumentare la
corsa poi consapevolezza che dobbiamo
avere di fronte alle a queste nuove
tecnologie che peraltro ci permettono
tante cose questi sono i miei lavori
riassunti di design e di architettura e
poi come dicevo prima il fatto di essere
una donna nel 2008 io ho fatto questa
mostra b come design non c'era la parola
donna
il riferimento era al ma castelli moglie
di giulio castelli fondatori della
kartell che era mia mia commissione
d'esame il mio maestro gazzaruso quando
lei mancata i giornali non hanno parlato
di lei come di zanuso di magistretti dei
castiglioni perché perché una donna
allora io di mia iniziativa
quando si è diretto fare questa mostra
in omaggio e lei che tra l'altro era
stata presidente dell'adi negli anni 60
quando si è conclusa la mostra
casualmente o forse non casualmente come
un passaggio di testimone
io sono diventata la seconda presidente
della di qui la vedete stata l'unica
donna presidente della de e in quel
periodo sicuramente la cosa era ancora
più eclatante a livello mondiale io sarò
secondo presidente di nuovo a seguito di
una donna che lo era stata negli anni
sessanta e sono felice di essere seconda
mi auguro che sia una serie di donne che
possono affermarsi questo era il
manifesto del
la mostra la cosa divertente è che logo
sembra un punto croce quindi è
autoironico perché tutte le donne che
venivano raccontate in questa mostra
certamente non avevano tempo da dedicare
al punto croce
però l'idea che non partiva con un
impulso di femminismo quanto di
valorizzazione del lavoro di tante donne
che se non fossero state messe in
evidenza da un'altra donna fosse non
sarebbero state riconosciute e poi
diciamo che questo essendo diventata poi
alla guida della di mi ha permesso di
girare il mondo di promuovere mostre
competizioni concorsi di portare il
compasso d'oro anche alla commissione
europea durante il semestre italiano e
poi a a bruxelles a lima a bogotà e in
giro per il mondo
che cosa quindi io voglio raccontarvi
alla fine due cose 1 che come donna
ogni donna può ottenere gli stessi
risultati di un uomo sembra una cosa
scontata da dirsi però vi assicuro che
io ho iniziato a fare l'architetto ormai
moltissimi anni fa e per anni e anni nei
cantieri sentivo dire buongiorno
ingegnere buongiorno geometra prego
avvocato ha certo signor e questo mi
dava molto fastidio ma nella mia
timidezza non osavo dire no scusi mi
deve chiamare al tetto
adesso rido dentro di me quando succede
però quando mi chiamano signora mi dà
comunque fastidio è la persona che mi
chiama signora mi risulta antipatica e
poi nel come proseguo del lavoro io
diffido di questa persona no finché
finché non capisce che io sono un
professionista e che come tale mi deve
trattare quando un giorno nel 2007 sono
state in questa riunione a copenaghen
dove si decideva della segreteria
dell'ex che poteva andare a torino che
poi torino ha perso ma poi come prima di
consolazione è stato dato l'incarico di
world design capital e oggi ci
ritroviamo a torino dopo quasi dieci
anni quindi grande soddisfazione e a
quella serata una donna sudafricana che
era seduta accanto a me mi disse
purtroppo nel mondo ci sono un sacco di
donne che sono in numero 2 nelle aziende
le associazioni fanno un lavoro disumano
si ammazzano di lavoro e poi però tutto
viene raccolto dal numero uno che
solitamente un uomo e io ho detto ma
anche peccato però e poi però ho capito
che ci sono delle paure delle resistenze
nelle donne nell'udire a se stessi in
primo luogo voglio essere numero uno
perché quando tu dici questo cominciano
dire armadi ripensa alla tua famiglia
del pensare ai tuoi figli
sembra una persona egoista semplicemente
perché vuoi essere una persona e quindi
mi sono detta va bene io voglio essere
il numero uno di una cosa molto piccola
come può essere la di certamente non è
una cosa impressionante
però ho capito che essendo una donna se
volevo fare quello che volevo dovevo
fare così assumendomi anche i rischi gli
impegni di quello che ciò comporta
perché molto spesso le donne fanno un
altra scelta che anche a volte una
scelta di comodo di mettersi in secondo
piano ma essere protette in mille
situazioni da qualcun altro
quindi diciamo che il passaggio duro e
dirlo se stessi io mi ricordo che l'ho
scritto su un foglio dal momento che
avevo scritto con grande vergogna poi
l'ho fatto vabbè qui siamo da presentare
pubbliche sono andata a rompere le
scatole le istituzioni per far dare dei
premi anche dalla di e non soltanto
dall'università eccetera eccetera
questo premio dei premi dell'innovazione
al quirinale prima ladri non c'era lì
dentro
la seconda cosa e ultima cosa
sono quasi alla fine del mio tempo
invece che voglio quindi diciamo un
messaggio per le donne di credere in se
stessi e fare quello che vogliono
assumendosi però tutti anche gli annessi
e connessi
ecco questa è un'immagine che ha messo
per farvi ridere
questo è ciò che insegnano le bambine
sarai biancaneve arriva il principe col
cavallo bianco e poi invece uno si
ritrova se lavora arrivare a casa la
sera e non potersi sedere a guardare la
televisione come giustamente vorrebbe ma
a fare anche il resto questa è un'altra
immagine che è divertente e la mostra
perché me l'ha regalato un uomo
professionista perché effettivamente
quello che capita
e poi questo è l'ultima cosa che dice
volevo raccontarvi riguarda la bellezza
in tutti questi anni io ho lottato con
l'idea che la bellezza fosse un valore
oggettivo ed economico
mi ricordo quante volte ho parlato con
imprenditori biellesi eccetera mi sono
oppure con i sindaci quando promuovevo i
concorsi di architettura ricevano un
architetto sissi ma noi abbiamo altri
problemi
e anche adesso a torino e ovunque devi
sempre lottare con i fatti economici
però ci sono infinite dimostrazioni di
aziende che attraverso il design
attraverso la bellezza sono diventate
leader nel mondo la lessi la abet
laminati e quindi la bellezza
interpretata come forza poi se voi
pensate alla chiesa come ho usato la
bellezza per convincere delle sue idee
dando un pugno nello stomaco
attraverso lo stupore alle persone che
entravano dentro a questi edifici oppure
certamente la pubblicità che tutti voi
vedete tutti i giorni che usa la
bellezza in tutti i modi per raggiungere
degli scopi commerciali ma assodato
questo cioè che c'è un valore economico
e per l'italia questo è un messaggio
importantissimo e ci sarà questa
riunione il 13 ottobre che ho fortemente
voluto su design and heritage per dare
un messaggio le istituzioni per
promuovere il nostro paese ormai le
persone non vengono più solo in italia
per il made in italy non ci conoscono
solo per quello ma vengono qui per
questo insieme di clima paesaggio beni
artistici e culturali moda design
prodotto vino cibo
tutto questo non è messo sistema non fa
un economia ognuno di questi settori
viaggio in modo separato e solo oggi ho
girato parecchio il mondo mi rendo conto
dell'unicità nel nostro paese di quanto
questo potrebbe rappresentare in termini
di economia di posti di lavoro per i
giovani e per luca per i non giovani
ovviamente e poi infine la bellezza è
anche un valore oggettivo è un mestiere
lavorare con la bellezza cioè non è una
questione di femminilità non è una
questione di buon gusto non è una
questione
di essere creativi e proprio che con
durata dentro di noi
io vi assicuro che partecipo giurie nel
mondo dove ci sono persone che arrivano
da culture completamente diverse
dall'africa dall'america dall'australia
e se dobbiamo scegliere fra 300 prodotti
10 o 11 tutti immediatamente d'accordo e
scegliamo la stessa cosa perché ci sono
delle regole proprio anche fisiche
connaturate dentro di noi che ci fanno
percepire dei rapporti di armonia che ci
sono nelle cose e quindi diciamo che a
questo punto il mio percorso mi sono
sentita rassicurata del averlo
intrapreso nonostante la mia berlesi ta
ecco allora io vi lascio con questo
c'era un immagine precedente che era
questa perché abbiamo il mio lavoro di
design di architetta un lavoro di team
collettivo
tutti pensano alle star ma il futuro non
sarà più delle star sia il design che
l'architettura sono ormai troppo
complesse per cui bisognerà lavorare in
team
questo è difficile da capire per gli
italiani che sono individualisti stiamo
pagando per questo ed è difficile capire
anche per i biellesi che sono ancora più
individualisti però il mio uno stimolo a
uscire fuori dal buco
cioè non possiamo stare nel nostro buco
al caldo dobbiamo aprirci verso il mondo
grazie
[Applauso]